I firmly believe that a training scene
can improve pretty much any film or TV
series Pride and Prejudice would have
been ten times better with a good
training scene when done right a
training scene or montage can be
incredibly motivating we see our
favorite on-screen heroes gave through
grueling regimes that test them mentally
and physically and that pushed them to
superhuman Heights we get inventive new
training ideas and pretty much an entire
character our core hero's journey
crammed into a few minutes of sweating
and grunting very often this is combined
with a rocking soundtrack and a
superhero worthy physique and the result
is a perfect shot of inspiration that's
more effective than any pre-workout when
it comes to getting pumped with that in
mind let's break down some of the best
training scenes in movies TV and anime
and look at what makes each one of them
so great Rocky Balboa you're gonna be
seeing a lot of the Rocky films
appearing on this list and that's
exactly as it should be
the training scene in Rocky Balboa is
short they might not be an instant
classic but the reason I love this one
personally is that it shows us that at
his ripe old age rocky and Stallone have
still got it seeing him training his way
out of old age of retirement to overcome
even greater odds than usual is epic and
incredibly moving I love it when we see
a hero broken-down and take them to
their lowest ebb like this only to then
train and come back just as strong as
they were before its triumphant and the
slow burn nature of the film up to that
point makes it all the sweeter as for
the training methods themselves they
start a lot more gentle befitting his
older age but soon escalate to much more
modern methods like hammering it tires
squatting and swinging kettlebells and
it all ends of course with another
iconic run up the stairs
this time with a little dog in tow let's
start building some hurtin bombs
[Music]
the matrix the first matrix film was
incredible for so many reasons
this is one of the films that got me
into martial arts and this scene is one
of the big reasons why it's pretty
different to Nia actually learns his
kungfu in an instant by a plug on the
back of his head they don't have
bluetooth in the matrix apparently and
so instead it's his ability to let go of
his mental restraints that's being
tested and trained here q an awesome
fight scene between superhuman martial
artists directed by the legendary
hyun-woo ping there's incredible music
just the right amount of wire work and
it's just a motivating and awesome scene
in general drunken master drunken master
is one of the classic films that
launched Jackie Chan's career and it
happens to showcase some of the most
creative and awesome training methods
put on film from balancing on large
buckets whilst filling them up with
water to being controlled like a puppet
and crushing nuts with his hands he
performs some pretty wicked hanging
sit-ups too and it all ends with Jackie
Chan's demonstration of the drunken
fighting style
Jackie's films from this era were often
filmed with long scenes of him
practicing martial arts forms and as a
testament to his sheer physicality that
this was so entertaining
Eero I really think there should have
been more superhero training scenes on
this list as it is there aren't as many
as you might think the honorable mention
goes to Batman Begins the training in
the Aero series almost makes up for that
though Stephen Amell is an incredible
shape and he appears to do this kind of
training for real which makes it that
much more authentic it began with the
classic Salmon Ladder scene and he's
been outdoing himself with inventive
body weight and functional training
since then Amal is so badass that even
took part in American Ninja Warrior and
performed really well in it want to
learn more about trading like Steve
enamel an arrow well then check out the
full video on the subject on this very
channel kickboxer jean-claude Van Damme
took a pretty decent stab at the
training scene with both bloodsport and
kickboxer while the film's pretty
similar
kickboxer has been more impressive
montage showcasing Jean Claude's insane
flexibility and high kicking ability
highlights also include roundhouse kicks
performed underwater
torturous leg stretching
vices and repeated Shing kicks against
bamboo trees a real training method used
by my Thai kickboxers okay
snake in the Eagles shadow war drunken
master is undoubtedly better named snake
in the Eagles shadow is actually my
favorite classic Jackie Chan kungfu
movie it features just as many awesome
inventive training moments more bowls of
water and eggs a crazy good v-sit more
actual martial arts and less gurning i'm
a huge fan of this film in general and
it's one of the reasons i started
training in martial arts that and the
interest of my step granddad who had
been doing all kinds of similar things
when i was a teen from snatching coins
from my own forearms to doing sit-ups
with sticks behind my head had to lift
buckets of water on my fingers in other
words i can relate yet for a few years
there I was pretty much living in an
anime which I was totally cool with
obviously Mulan one of the things you'll
notice and many of these scenes is just
how awesome the music often is Donny
Osmond's I'll make them out of you from
Milan has to take the cake here
[Music]
fun fact Jackie Chan actually son a
Cantonese version of this song the
animation is great and is an uplifting
scene where Mulan is not only developing
the strength and speed she needs but
also winning the respect of her
colleagues a shout-out to Hercules here
as well which takes a lot of inspiration
from Rocky and Superman actually that's
a pretty cool combination Rocky 3 this
scene from the rocky franchise is iconic
for all sorts of reasons Stallone was an
absolutely incredible shape at the time
Apollo proved to be an awesome training
buddy / coach and of course there's the
ridiculous ending where they leap around
in the sea hugging and the crop-top only
in the 80s the bulk of the training
actually focuses a lot on Stallone speed
rhythm and footwork this time which
makes it a bit different
along with overcoming the fear that's
holding him back with a little help and
encouragement from Adrian
never back down ever back down as a
cheesy movie there's kind of like a
combination between High School Musical
and martial arts but it's actually
pretty awesome the training montage
especially saved the soft-rock false
pretense fits the training scenes
perfectly and there are some creative
training methods on display here such as
using a ladder for monkey bars
kettlebell juggling and throwing bricks
around the foot race on the docks is
also very similar to the scene from
Rocky 3 so props for showing some
respect there Dragon Ball Z Goku trains
and increased gravity
Dragon Ball Z is packed with awesome
training scenes and methods from chasing
monkeys to training in the hyperbolic
time chamber to enduring huge
gravitational forces some of the most
memorable training scenes they were
during Goku's trip to Planet Namek where
he trains to fight freezer it culminates
in the gravity machine breaking and
forcing Goku to go beyond his limits
just to survive
props returning a training scene into an
entire storyline here once all is said
and done Goku arrives on there making
takes apart the ginyu force and one of
the coolest scenes in the series and yes
I've heard you requests I'll be doing a
video on weighted calisthenics very soon
Vegeta trains for Super Saiyan while
Goku did it first Vegeta did it better
first we get to see him go super saiyan
for the first time along with the
awesome vegeta super saiyan theme
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me see a far more intense version of
the gravity training complete with
incredible art and animation he goes on
to train on the desolate planet and
pushes himself to the point of near
death training doesn't get much more
badass than that and the scene features
some of her cheetahs best lines - I
decided to continue my training in the
solitude of space I wish I had the kind
of life where I could say I decided to
continue my training in the solitude of
space and people wouldn't laugh at me
the Karate Kid
the modern version that is look the
original has to be one of the most well
known training scenes of all time but
that said the newer version has Jackie
Chan on it and sweeping shots of the
Great Wall of China and Jaden Smith
dodging tennis balls must be honest the
crane kick from the original scene is
just ridiculous
this film is filled with plenty of other
small training moments to tributes to
the original film and a great piece of
music can port - this film was better
than it had any right to be
I wish Jackie Chan would train me
colourful lifting everything we do
without doing he live scene how we put
on a jacket
I would pick after Jackie then live
scene how we treat people
everything it's code for backe the
grappler backing the grappler over some
great training and fight scenes but
episodes three and four where Barca goes
to train with and I have to take the
cake
baki is training in the wilderness
climbing cliffs kicking trees and
running with boulders strapped to his
back which is always a hit what really
sets this apart is the explanation
behind how Bucky pushes himself beyond
normal human limits which is based very
loosely on real science he learns to
override his pain barrier by releasing
endorphins and to access heightened
reflexes by tapping into his near-death
focus essentially a flow state and it
all ends with them fighting a massive
ape which is pretty hardcore
[Music]
and of course we can't forget the film
started it all the original rocky film
this has got a ton of iconic training
concepts and ideas from chasing chickens
around to running up the steps in
Philadelphia the music from bill Conti
has to be the training music to end all
training music and if it wasn't for this
film we wouldn't have training montages
like we do today the whole thing is
incredibly triumphant and it's just a
fantastic classic scene by any movie
standards rocky 4 this has to be among
my most watched film scenes of all time
and it really is the pinnacle of all
training montages we have in fact two
back-to-back montages here with music
from the excellent survivor and Vance de
colo of Transformers the movie fame
respectively the contrast between
Drago's modern high-tech training setup
and Rocky's back to basics log cabin
workout make for a great visual metaphor
and there are tons of awesome feats of
strength and inventive training methods
on display here
highlights includes the legs shoulder
pressing a carriage full of people
performing Bruce Lee's Dragon Flag and
pulling a sledge the climax which
features Stallone roaring his opponents
name from on top of a mountain is about
as iconic as it gets so that's a pretty
great way to end this video too
[Music]
you